okay
i think we're live
good morning
hello depending on where in the world
you are
um
in language learning uh motivation as i
have often said
motivation and time those are the two
key factors you have to be motivated and
you have to spend the time
and if we are learning on our own or
even if we're learning in a classroom
environment with a teacher
uh sometimes we have the feeling we're
not making any progress
so it's easy to lose that motivation
so let me just
uh so today i want to show you how
keeping track of your activity
through various
statistics can be tremendously helpful
in keeping you motivated and giving you
a sense of how you're doing
and i'm going to do that by reviewing
some of my own statistics in different
languages as well as the statistics of
two people who
contacted me and said that i could um
you look at their statistics so
let's get uh that's about it we went on
for a good hour last time i'm i'm happy
to answer questions it makes for a long
video on youtube some people may not
want to stick around for the whole hour
that's fine too and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to talk for a while here
and then i'm going to
try to answer any questions that you may
uh post and it's again the world of
technology i have
the uh
sort of youtube video of this on my ipad
just beside me here so that i can see
the questions and comments which i can't
see while i'm making the video here
on my computer
so
let us get going with sharing the screen
so
hopefully you can all see my screen this
is the last item that i was doing
in arabic but
let us go
to so where do we find our statistics on
link
we go to my little picture here
and uh
i go down to my profile whoops i lost it
there we go profile
and
up comes these statistics
and of course i can change them i can
look at them the last seven days
i can look at known words
or other items that i can look at at
different time periods different
languages and so forth now before i
review my statistics
i'm going to review
the statistics of two
of my listeners here
uh who contacted me so let's make sure i
first of all
edward finch sent me his spreadsheet
that he keeps
and so what he does he keeps meticulous
records on a spreadsheet when he started
they won
what he considered to be his motivation
level he presumably assigns that some
subjective number how many minutes he
listened how many minutes he read how
many minutes he spoke writing total
links created total known words and a
little comment
on how he felt that day i mean this is
to my mind this is extreme it doesn't
take a lot of time to do and i think
even creating
this spreadsheet
is in itself motivating you look forward
to you're motivated to put more down
uh
because that's going to indicate to you
that you are in fact making progress and
so he's able to graph these down here
uh
one thing about language learning which
is very important
is that
you know unlike some activities the more
time you put in the better you will get
even if you are not
if you don't realize that you're making
progress you are because you are
exposing your brain to more and more of
the language the brain cannot help but
learn
so activity level equals learning even
if you don't notice it i i feel this is
and it's like golf for example doesn't
matter how much time i put into
golf i don't improve
uh because i can't seem to master the
sort of uh you know body
muscle memory
thing that i need in order to perform
well on the golf course but i know that
in all of my language learning the more
time i put in the higher my activity
level the better so this was edward now
let us look at another person well that
one was mine here what did we do here
that was okay we go here so
rough jp
that's his username he sent me his
username by the way if you go to the
community
here i'll just step back a step
here we are uh if you go to the
community you can put someone's name in
here
rough jp
search for them
and
he's learning japanese here we see the
list of
people this is their street this is
their known words so you can actually
follow
what other people are doing so that's
also motivating to know where you stand
uh vis-a-vis other people
so here's steve i'm not doing japanese
so i'm at reg 158 i have a few things
i've done in japanese but not very much
uh but if we look up rough jp
and we there's sometimes there's more
than one person with the same or similar
username so we get the rough jp
and we see
that in this last week he has 32 known
words
95 links
so he's on track with his links
uh he hasn't moved many links to
sort of known or hasn't learned many
that means that he hasn't been doing a
lot of um you know reviewing which is
fine
to me
creating the links is where you start
the process you get words into your
database which you then will meet again
and again
and gradually learn them so that's a
good level of activity his words of
reading is up to snuff
i would spend more time listening uh
you'll see my statistics in a short
while but i spend a lot more time
reading listening rather
um writing and speaking again i have
started increasing my amount of speaking
again if he does that on italki it won't
be trapped at length
if he and so we'll look at that as it
affects you know my uh uh
activity so this is achievements he
ranked 107 on an active challenge so
these are some of the other ways you can
look at his avatar for those who like
the avatar these are different ways that
measuring your level of activity
helps to keep you motivated so this is
last week let's look at last month
so last month
even here he's
creating a lot of links
learned a few but still no listening
and he's very strong on the reading so i
would say that i would balance it
with with more
listening see no listening at least not
listening that's tracked at a
uh he may be listening say on itunes on
his mp3 player uh but i i recommend that
if you are studying lessons and he is
because we are tracking he's reading a
lot so he's obviously going through
lessons he should be
[Applause]
creating a playlist and adding these the
lessons that he studies to a playlist
and then listening on the playlist and
that way you can be sure
that the listing is tracked even if you
listen to the lesson while reading it it
will track as listening time so my
advice
to rafael here is do more listening
all right so now let's move to
my statistics
oh by the way i just signed up for a lot
of
a lot of conversation both in farsi or
persian
and in arabic
but
let us go so in order to
find my profile i will go here
and uh
so now this what i call the swoosh
uh is not available when i visit
somebody else's account so i cannot see
raphael's
you know swoosh graph
but it will be added in the future so
you actually will in the future have the
the opportunity to go and visit somebody
else's profile and see their historic
level of activity so if we look at me in
persian or remember now that i'm
studying two languages at the same time
persian and arabic so in the last seven
days
so therefore i'm not going to be
maintaining my streak because i'm going
three days on three days off so i lose
my streak okay
uh one of the things we have instituted
is we have or will institute is the
ability if you break your streak you can
use your coins to repair your streak but
that's
coming later on
so in in persian i have added 100 in
this last week i've added 128 known
words i've created a lot of links
i've learned a lot of links so this is
because
in persian
i have a lot of uh
i have a lot of links that i have
created which i'm now slowly converting
to known
i listen 3.3 hours
my reading is down a bit no writing and
i spoke
uh one hour one hour of speaking in this
past week
if i look at let's say no
what i you know these are my statistics
that i can read but i what i find very
instructive is to look at the graph here
so if for example when did i start
learning
varsity
person so what we see here is that i got
quite interested in it in sort of
uh
you know
july august here
and then in preparation for going to
morocco i stopped doing anything
uh
and then once i returned from morocco
uh
you know towards the end of december and
certainly into january i got more active
in
persian
but now that i decided to combine it
with arabic it's
off a little bit but all of this
activity is always cumulative
so i think this is very important you
know uh
let's look at another that's links
created for example so we'll see the
same pattern again
active initially not so active
quite a bit more active but it's all
constantly adding so to the extent that
you are
uh active it's all adding to your
ability in the language and if we look
at arabic
uh let's see here we are arabic
here again if you see that my all-time
activity in arabic you see that i
initially got interested in december
of 2017
kind of messed around a little bit got
quite keen around march
and so i have these little you know uh
period spurts of activity i'm at a lower
level now because i'm combining it with
persian
and if i look at let's say listening
which is perhaps the best indicator of
my level of activity
you'll see that i got quite interested
in listening here and i've been
listening somewhat less here and but all
of the while
my listening activity is just
more and more exposure to the language
and i know from experience let's say if
i go for reading
i know from experience that all of the
reading i'm doing
in spurts all of the listening that i'm
doing
is going to enable me to learn the
language
uh if i look at for example perhaps the
first language that i i started
at link is russian
so
you can see here now here the numbers
get a little bit difficult to read
but i started russian ad link
in july of 2007
and i have had these spurts of activity
in russian
and uh
so if i look at just the spurts i'll say
reading
and of course this is only the reading
that's at link now i did some reading
outside of link as well
but it's all cumulative
and so if i look at my known words total
here again you'll see that i was very
active here in this period but my known
words in russian is now up to some 80 or
90 000. so in time it can become a lot
of known words if you stay with the
program
so uh
okay
now
the thing about listening in russian is
we didn't track the listening initially
i was doing most of my listening simply
on on itunes and it wasn't being tracked
so this is not
really a good indicator and and recently
since about 2010 i've hardly been doing
any listening to russian because i've
been active in other languages so and
and the fun thing is if you're doing
more than one language you know i can
look at my check for example
so here again very active at an early
period and i haven't done much since if
i look at uh you know known words
again a similar pattern but the point is
that it's cumulative so even if i was
very active 2011 2012
i had a brief spurt in here maybe when i
went to
the bratislava polyglot conference but
essentially i haven't done much with
czech since
uh i can look up my korean level
activity which is one
that i've been off and on on
korean
okay so here again
spurts of activity here and there but
it's all accumulative and i can go back
to my korean and all of this you know
cumulative effect of the known words or
the listening it'll still be there and
very quickly i'll recover to where i was
before
so
that's kind of a brief presentation of
uh you know just touching on the issue
of statistics and how it can be
motivating
now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to see if
uh now let's get over here and see what
sorts of questions i've got here and
maybe i should uh no okay now maybe i
will uh
we can leave the screen that way let's
just move this over here all right
so greetings from venezuela blah blah
blah hello i'm from brazil south america
seems like a great place to visit yes
welcome edwin finch what's up guys good
morning let's see
have i ever thought of learning a dead
language like latin we have latin at
link i may the trouble with languages
is that there's so many that i i could
be interested in in learning it's it's
just a matter of deciding where to spend
my time right now i'm focused on arabic
persian and perhaps turkish
what should i be doing for learning
japanese and just do the range of things
that we recommend you do at link listen
read review speak
how many hours of listening do you have
in russian okay i can't comment on that
because
most of the listening i did was was uh
in fact i'll put russian up here
let's go to russian but it's not a good
indicator because we didn't we didn't
have the playlist
for most of the time that i was learning
russian so this doesn't uh but you know
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
hours this is known words so the
listening is not going to be an accurate
indicator
not going to be an activity i would say
thousands of hours i listen every day i
would download first of all i listened
to audiobooks of the russian classic
novels uh i listened i downloaded
interviews off the internet
thousands of hours
for work was it necessary to take a test
to prove your fluency in
language the only time i had to take a
test was uh well
two obviously i studied in france at an
institute politik and so i was taking
tests in french but the test was about
international relations international
economics whatever but it was in french
and then when i studied mandarin chinese
as an employee of the canadian
government i had to take what is known
as the
british diplomatic service exam
and so in mandarin i had to translate
from english to chinese chinese to
english write the diplomatic note and
all this kind of stuff
uh so
your voice is so clearly hurricane good
damn that's mine so cool yeah
uh okay hi mr steve do you guys often
update the link contents especially
chinese content
okay with regard to the chinese or any
language content
we do not we cannot be creating content
all the time for 30 odd 33 languages i
think it is so we have created some like
the many stories but otherwise we rely
on people
who offer content to us
uh sometimes it's language sites that
want
uh give us a sampling uh so that people
will visit them or members who
uh
who you know contribute they speak to
their
partner friends spouse wife husband
whatever child
and then they transcribe it and give it
to us we definitely want
uh we want to uh get more content please
if you can provide us additional content
the other thing is we would like to sell
high quality content and so we have
approached uh different publishers and
they're often slow and getting back to
us but we would love to be able to sell
good quality content i think people
would buy it integrated with the link
system i've had to do this for my own
use uh you know importing uh asimil
and uh you know la modern and these
contents uh but it's it's time consuming
and i can't share those because we don't
have the copyright
uh
okay no i can't sort of joseph asks if i
can no i mean i'd have to have it ahead
of time
it's simply not possible for me now to
to analyze your uh your statistics
uh
where did you post yours okay yeah
people who had their statistics looked
at if this is something people want to
do they can email me and make sure you
tell me
your uh
username and which language you want me
to look at
um
it doesn't matter if you're doing more
than one language i can also do that
uh
so
okay hey i'll
first time watching blah blah blah if
you're helping me i'm going to start
practicing speaking yeah speaking
speaking is good i have found that that
and i mentioned this elsewhere speaking
does several things first of all it
helps you create content because a good
tutor will give you a report with all
the words and phrases you struggled with
and and the really good theaters give
you a audio recording so that you can uh
you know really get at the words and
phrases that you struggle with
uh okay
so i have a question specifically for
french speakers i'm an intermediate or
has been doing a lot of lessons but i
need to read more any book
recommendations you know i often get
asked that kind of question it depends
on your interests
find something of interest to you
and if you can import it into link so
much the better and there's lots of
e-text out there
that you can import and then you can
really work on learning their words and
phrases
okay
do you
what ways do you practice speaking aside
from a tutor
uh
only with my tutors if i get to now
i have a persian tutor two persian
tutors they're very good
uh first of march is my wife's birthday
we've invited a number of our neighbors
over
one of them
a couple are originally from iran so i
will be
springing my limited persian on
this couple but i have relatively little
opportunity to use the language so
mostly i speak uh with my tutor on
online uh and the advantage if it's just
if it's a linked tutor is that you get a
detailed report with a lot of words and
phrases
as i said do you think learning hanja is
important in korean
of course i have hanja from having
studied chinese and japanese so i miss
the hanja in korean i wish there were
more
i wish they still use the
chinese characters and when i look a
word up when i'm doing korean i will go
to the dictionary and get the hanja and
import it into the hint so that anyone
coming behind me who looks at that word
will find the chinese characters with it
i think it's extremely helpful but if
someone has no background in chinese or
japanese then perhaps it's not that
important
uh
how different is the grammar between the
romance languages
i would say that the grammar is like
in each of these languages each of them
has like a 10
little rules that are different even
between portuguese and spanish there are
little things that are different but
it's like 90
the same i think the grammar is more
similar than the vocabulary
and the vocabulary is over 80
uh
that's my impression that's not a
scientific
uh scientific uh
answer
uh okay steve the politician in spain
and catalonia right now is very
interesting do you think you'll ever get
around learning you know i would love to
learn catalan when i was in barcelona i
bought a book on the history of
catalonia in catalan i can basically
read it
so then the only question is
you know what would be the special
motivation that gets me to learn catalan
because right now i'm kind of focused on
arabic persian and eventually turkish
if i was going to spend let's say two
weeks in catalonia catalunya i would
probably make an effort to learn catalan
just for that period
uh
okay
okay yeah levi ukraine
okay here's the deal i am flying into
kiev
on the 17th of may i will go down to
nipro
where i will meet with these people i've
been supporting uh
an nga ngo rather it's a group of ladies
who help
the old and the sick and the young
children and stuff in the sort of war
zone uh
so i'm going to go with them and they've
been you know using the little bit of
money that i send them to build the
playgrounds in schools and buy
diapers for old people and reading
glasses and a whole bunch of stuff uh so
then once i'm
back from there
hopefully the war doesn't heat up
then i will probably make my way to
levive
sort of
call it the last week in may okay
uh now
i'm learning swedish do you recommend me
to learn it by english so i can gain two
languages even though this is not my
mother tongue
uh it depends i mean if you speak
english well
why not uh there's gonna be more
material available
uh based on english
probably than in your mother tongue i
don't know what your mother tongue is
um but uh i would do that i would do
that definitely
sure learn uh if you speak a language
well you can learn a a third language
using the second language that you use
well and they both improve
okay
uh tagalog
okay
yeah somebody said here mark said uh how
much interesting content can you find
obviously
but in my case instead of arabic and
persian i was motivated for other
reasons and then i struggled to find
interesting content
uh
okay
all right well good we've kept it a
little shorter here
uh
oh here's did you create link how did it
come to be
uh so my son mark and i founded link
and it's interesting it's it's uh i told
this story before i was learning
cantonese listening to chinese radio
here in vancouver
and heard about a chinese immigrant
who arrived at the airport and had all
his savings
some of these immigrants very unwisely
they arrived with ten thousand dollars
in a bag
and so he had that money stolen at the
airport and this was reported uh on the
news
uh on this uh chinese cantonese radio
station that i was listening to so i
contacted this chinese uh organization
and said uh
you know uh if
um
you know this person apparently this
person was in i.t and in
you know computer technology i said we
will happily give this person a job if
it works out he has a job if it doesn't
work out we've helped him out since he
had this unfortunate experience on
arriving in canada so we had this person
with us for six or seven months realized
that even though this person had a high
score in toeic test of english as uh
whatever it is toeic english exam he
really had a lot of trouble
communicating so we started developing
this system because we were we did have
computer expertise in the office we were
in the wood industry the forest industry
and we were building uh software systems
for sawmills which is what he was
working on with us
and but we got some of our technical
people to start developing a system to
help him improve his english he
eventually went back to china
but then we tried to interest the
canadian government in this to help
immigrants uh of course the canadian
government is so bureaucratic
they were not interested
and then we decided to expand it into a
multi-language platform so that's the
answer
uh now
uh if you had to learn a language from
scratch without link what type of
content would you use is a question
uh well
uh
if i don't have link i go and buy the
usual starter books normally i would buy
two or three teach yourself colloquial
and uh you know spend a fair amount of
time on those going over the same
material through two or three different
books
and
with access to stuff that's on the
internet i'd go look around for
you know
whatever's there
i would certainly focus on any reading
material this is what i i did for
languages before link i would look for
readers that had glossaries because the
one thing i would want to avoid
is having to use a conventional
dictionary for the simple reason that
every time you look something up you
forget it right away and therefore you
need some kind of a system like link
where you keep track of words that you
have looked up and have a chance to kind
of
review them you have a chance to see
them again uh you're reminded that
you've seen them before so essentially
it was my struggling with
other methods of learning conventional
books that got me into
link
so
now
would you ever learn dutch well my wife
and i played golf the other day with a
couple from holland i'm sort of
moderately motivated i've had a look at
dutch at length it doesn't look very
difficult but again it is a question of
where to spend one's time and so right
now i'm focused on
persian and arabic
do you know any good podcasts with
transcripts or books in chinese well
when i was sort of refreshing my chinese
when i was in beijing for example
there's lots of audio cds there's
xiangshang there's audio cds on history
on philosophy on you name it novels and
stuff
so i mean
you know get get for example i i know
you can get some of the sort of early
20th century novels you can get
audiobooks and find the text
online uh otherwise you might want to
look at youtube where you can import
videos from youtube
into link and study them on link
so
you know you have to look around
now it can probably be better than that
steve do you know any good podcast so if
you don't have transcripts you should
also look into this automatic
transcription service uh i guess you
have to have enough of a demand to make
it worthwhile but for 20 or 30 dollars
you get five hours worth of
transcription and it's quite good it
even works for arabic
does your spouse learn languages as well
yes she does kind of more she
not as
in-depth as i do but she's quite fluent
in five or six languages
uh
she
you know was born in macau father's
chinese mother is from costa rica so
some exposure to obviously spanish as
well as obviously cantonese and then uh
you know she's learned mandarin with me
because when i was learning mandarin
in hong kong she'd come to the various
get-togethers we had with
the teachers and stuff and then we lived
in japan and we i you know travel in
france quite a bit and she speaks in
french and so she likes it but she's not
sort of a
you know fanatic like i am
uh
have you thought of updating your book
or writing another one you know i should
it's again a matter of finding the time
i should i really should
uh okay
you said once it isn't worth you listen
to something without a transcript but is
it worth listening to your radio on your
smartphone because blah blah blah okay
yeah i have i find it it's i can't say
it has no
impact but when you're listening to
something where you don't understand
anything i find it very tiring and i'm
not sure that that's as good a thing to
do
as listening to material where you have
a chance
of making it comprehensible don't forget
we always talk about comprehensible
input
some languages
languages tests don't have speaking
sections so i don't know okay
thanks i'll check it out what do you
think about sentence mining
i'm not quite sure what sentence mining
is
but i i kind of tend to feel that i know
there are teaching methods that focus on
sentences as a sort of core unit to
learn
and i feel
that uh it's phrases that because the
phrases repeat and the sentences tend to
be more unique so
yeah i'm not big into focusing on
sentences but
different people have different
approaches
[Applause]
why do you think dual language is
popular because it's free basically
symbol is
how long do you guys study your
target language per day is a question so
right now i find that i'm spending
probably 45 minutes in the morning 45
minutes in the evening reading and
linking and then i will probably get in
another hour of listening every day and
this is you know half the weekend
persian have to be weak in
arabic
[Music]
from your experience how much
helped me in mandarin cantonese because
i understand kenji yeah i mean
kanji is such a big obstacle in learning
chinese or japanese
that if you have sort of uh
you know tackled that issue in one
language then
it really helps you in in in another you
you know what the characters mean you
may have to learn new pronunciation
uh
but structurally of course chinese is
very different from
japanese so you still have to learn
the structure but you have 50 of the
vocabulary
uh pronounced somewhat differently
sometimes with a slightly different
meaning and you know what the the sort
of ideogram you know the graphic
representation of those words is so big
help if you have kanji
do you find you have a slightly
different personality when you speak a
foreign language yeah to some extent i
think that's true
i think that's true
uh after how many known words you really
start to feel comfortable listening
you know if we're talking about
listening to authentic real content
i found the number is surprisingly high
so if i'm listening to uh you know and
typically non-fiction is easier than
literature
but i think thirty thousand you know
twenty thirty thousand bearing in mind
that the that number
known words numbers is gonna have
different meaning in different languages
depending on how much the language is
inflected and stuff but it's in that 30
000 range
uh but if if you are you know have a
very limited range of discussion with
someone i think the many stories really
prepare me for sort of a limited you
know chit chat type of situation but if
i'm listening to anything of uh you know
significance podcast whatever i need a
lot more
uh
all right
i think we're nearing the end here uh we
try to keep these to half an hour
uh thank you very much let me just stop
the screen sharing so that i can at
least end up
interacting with people all right here
we are so
thank you very much uh
please let me know what you're
interested in if you want me to focus on
different aspects of language learning
of link and stuff with any other
questions
uh okay how do you memorize vocabulary
uh
what do you first what do you think
about learning chinese with opinions
through link for someone whose goal is
solely speaking and reading through
league well i don't know how you can
read just with pinyin
so you could use just pinyin if you're
if your goal is just to speak but
reading in chinese means reading
characters how do you elevate yourself
from intermediate to native okay
i've said this before i don't think we
become native but we can become very
very proficient and it's simply time you
just have to put in a lot of time
listening and reading and then
eventually as you're more and more
comfortable because you understand more
and more then you can engage in more and
more meaningful conversations with
people and eventually to be like a
native you have to speak a lot so the
listening and reading builds up your
potential but if you really want to be
you know that high level of proficiency
you eventually have to get to where you
speak a lot and even write a lot
uh blah blah blah
how do you say hi steve i have a habit
of learning
bite side mouths of several languages
what do you think is it better to focus
on just a two or three yeah
well you know
obviously if you are
in the habit of learning bite-size
amounts of several languages that means
you like explore exploring languages so
if you like exploring languages you know
do that if your goal is to become very
proficient in one or two then you have
to focus on one or two
but there's nothing wrong with being a
bit of a dilite to to get a flavor of
how these different languages work which
i've been doing to some extent i had a
brief fleeing at uh you know romanian i
had a brief fling at greek because i was
going to those countries now those
languages have lapsed uh but i can go
back there again so it's really a matter
of what you want to do
i can't i can't really advise you there
but if you want to achieve a decent
level in one you got to focus for quite
a while like
a year or something like that
uh hard to figure out what vowels to use
when reading new words in written arabic
okay first of all
you know
i read on link so i have my text to
speech and everything i read i have the
natural voice audio for and of course i
know that the text-to-speech audio is
not
always accurate but it's an indication
of how the word is pronounced what the
vowels are
and
because i find that the use of the
haruka and that it just it's clutter
and eventually i'm going to have to read
without that and when i find an article
on al jazeera it doesn't have that so
i've avoided that
but i am aware of what those little you
know
diacritics mean
i tend not to use them and it's not only
an issue of the vowels it's also an
issue of where the sort of
certain consonants are going to
emphasize and you hang in there on those
etcetera so
uh
yeah i i tend to
my strategy is more to get used to the
words i see them i know this words i
know how it's pronounced and eventually
if i have enough listening and reading
most of the words that i encounter i
will have encountered before and so i
will know how they're pronounced rather
than relying on my ability to you know
decipher decode uh although i try and uh
i get better in time
uh it's hard to figure out what votes
are you subscribed no
i don't know what qdp is
would you rather speak threefold i would
fluently or speak 30 languages but at a
basic level
who knows i mean both are valid
uh
i don't know what qdp is
what is pewdiepie qdp
i have no idea have you studied
esperanto no
uh who is the best polyglot you've ever
met
um
difficult to say but there are some very
good ones that show up at the polyglot
conference richard simcott luca
lamporiello
a number of them i can't think there are
many good ones
what do you think of scottish gaelic
it's not something i'm about to study
not very many speakers but obviously
it's
for some people that could be very
interesting
i
have could heard clearly understand but
i need how can i enhance my listening
level
enhance your listening level by doing a
lot of listening and reading and try to
listen to things and then read and then
listen again
how long would you believe it would take
for a fluent spanish speaker to pick up
italian through length three months
uh how we can memorize a lot of sentence
in a short period of time i don't
believe in memorization
okay
that's it
do you read
100's
no okay i'm gonna call it here
all right well thank you very much
and look for the next one let me know
what you'd like to have me talk about
and hopefully you're all working hard on
your 90 day challenge bye for now